"Goodnight Moon" by Margaret Wise Brown.
Pictures by Clement Hurd.
In the great green room, there was a telephone and a red balloon...
...and a picture of the cow jumping over the moon.
And there were three little bears sitting on chairs.
And two little kittens and a pair of mittens.
And a little toy house.
And a young mouse and a comb and a brush and a bowl full of mush.
And a quiet old lady who was whispering "hush."
Goodnight room.
Goodnight moon.
Goodnight cow jumping over the moon.
Goodnight light and the red balloon.
Goodnight bears and goodnight chairs.
Goodnight kittens and goodnight mittens.
Goodnight clocks and goodnight socks.
Goodnight little house and goodnight mouse.
Goodnight comb and goodnight brush.
Goodnight nobody, goodnight mush.
And goodnight to the little old lady whispering "hush."
Goodnight stars, goodnight air.
Goodnight noises everywhere.